hi there Steve Kaufman um I am going to
talk about language here I saw the
however I did see the Republican debate
debate you know the expression in
English empty barrels make the most
noise Trump is certainly the emptiest
barrel on the stage just a blustering
buffoon it's depressing to think that
he's in the lead and in fact just
watching the you know the schoolboy spat
that went on that was supposed to be a
political debate asst is pretty
depressing all around but I'm not going
to talk about that I'm going to talk
about language learning and sort of the
two the two in the yin and the yang of
language learning let's call it
obviously language learning is about
communicating it's about meaning it's
about substance and therefore we're
going to learn the language from
contents of interest to us and when we
talk we want to communicate things that
make sense we want to have meaningful
conversations and yet we do need a
certain amount of exercising of
overworking certain muscles of
overworking certain patterns in the
language so we have sometimes refer to
it as that the big picture and the nuts
and bolts or sort of top-down bottom-up
but we kind of need both so just a quick
comment someone pointed out to me that
when Mark Zuckerberg made his Chinese
speech to those University students in
Beijing who were an elite group of
students and he spoke to them in Chinese
many of the students that were not very
impressed because they wanted to hear
something of substance from Mark
Zuckerberg and his Chinese is not really
good enough to actually have a really
meaningful exchange with these students
all of whom speak english much better
than he speaks Chinese so really in the
interest of communication he should have
spoken in English after perhaps a brief
introduction in Chinese because the the
authenticity
either the the substance of the
communication is so important and that's
why I like to listen to things that
relate the history and soph and so on
but some degree of exercise we also need
so I was thinking about this as i went
off to my 24 hour fitness which is
located not too far from me here in in
indio california and not only do they
have a room full of all this exercise
equipment but then they have individual
rooms where twice last week I went to a
thing called boot camp where this lovely
lady just pushed us through our paces
where I was just exhausted between
jumping and stretching and push-ups and
God knows what so what is that how does
that relate to language honey you know I
was thinking of the tremendous cost of
university education a very poor return
on the money invested where you know
professors are not that interested in
teaching they're more interested in
doing research for their peers which is
a very little interest to anyone it's a
bloated bureaucracy it costs a fortune
whether it's paid for by the student or
by the taxpayer it is very expensive now
if we had a 24 hour fitness intellectual
fitness language fitness place for
eckers I paid $25 a month to belong to
24 hour fitness and I can use all their
equipment and I can go to all these
sessions zoom by you Jam you know I
don't know what else there is here
there's a whole schedule of stuff and I
can drop into all of them if I want all
four twenty-five dollars now what if I
could go down there and I've always I do
a lot of my language learning while
exercising so if we have a class where
we work on the subjunctive in French or
Spanish or verbs of motion in Russian or
polish or whatever it might be and so
someone was up there leading us through
these exercises and we were repeating
certain phrases or answering questions
and repeating them for an hour focusing
on let's say five basic patterns in a
language because after all there's not a
nun limb
number of these patterns there's a
limited number of them so you could
choose to go to a boot camp or Zumba
where the emphasis would be on the
subjunctive in Spanish or something I
mean it's an unrealistic idea but I
throw it out there and similarly you
could get on a treadmill and you could
switch to different languages and they
would make sure that they would have
content on there that was at your level
and you would pay $25 a month to go down
there and access their exercise
equipment and participate in their
glasses and you could either be doing
movies on your supper for half an hour
or you could be working on the
subjunctive so you would be combining
both the you know substantial
content-based authentic interesting
stuff while exercising or you would be
focusing on exercising certain aspects
of the language and I think we would
improve a lot doing that I think the
whole idea that to learn the language we
have to sit around and talk to each
other sit around and listen to
classmates who can't speak the language
stumble through reading or talking or
explaining to me it's just a waste of
time so I throw that out there just as
an idea to get the ball rolling and I
look forward to your comments now I got
my remote here and see if I turn this
off correctly there you go look for an
earring from you oh stop
you